it's over the top just like the movie is
it's completely indulgent hey what's up
everybody I'm Jonathan Bennett aka Aaron
Samuels and I am so excited because
today we're gonna be making a recipe for
my new parody cookbook for Mean Girls
fans the Byrne cookbook
you guys ready to melt check it like
it's 2004 so obviously Mean Girls was my
first movie and I'm so honored to be a
part of it and after Mean Girls I went
on to host a bunch of food competition
shows like cake Wars and Halloween wars
and it was awesome and then I realized I
need to marry my love for food with my
love for pop culture I thought why not
make an amazing book where people can
come together make the food watch the
movie and relive some of their favorite
moments with some of their best friends
and sometimes we all need a partner in
crime just to make sure we're doing
everything right so I teamed up with my
favorite chef Nikki Martin to help me
write the book Nikki get in loser
it's desserts we're making a milkshake
if I was a plastic I would definitely be
Lindsay Lohan not like Lindsay Lohan's
character I just want to be Lela it's
fun being part of pop culture and being
Aaron Samuels and for a lot of years I
didn't like it but what happened was
when my dad got sick we went to a
restaurant and he had these girls come
and take a photo with me and I was like
dad do we have to take photos all the
time and he goes when was the last time
you saw people that happy all these
girls are like looking at the pictures
and they're giggling and like one's
calling her mom and she's like shaky and
she's crying and that's when I realized
that Mean Girls is more than just a
movie it's part of their life and so
like I decided to just lean into it it's
an honor to be a part of people's lives
it's the milkshake that you want to make
with your friends push the coffee table
out of the way and get right in the
middle of the living room and do the
little Kylie Jorge dance and watch the
movie and dance in your living room I
mean you know all the moves to the
Jingle Bell Rock you know how it goes
and Nikki what do you think did we do a
good job I think we crushed it oh yeah
let's taste it all right yep you need
this milkshake and this book mmm go
watch Mean Girls why not oh oh yes
you